[Music]
the weekend says he's still
buzzing from last night after that
13-minute spectacle complete with neon
lit casinos
fireworks and dancers and bandages but
the toughest part
well the show's executive producer told
me it's not what you might think
i don't know if it's come out or not but
you know that jacket was 40 pounds
what why because it was real rubies you
know the first couple days it was like
getting to where he could move his arms
because
you know rubies are not the most
flexible things in the world
right so it was like day one it was a
little like
i'm a robot there was a lot of talk
about him putting in his own money
what did the money go to probably that
jacket
the givenchy jacket took four
embroiderers more than 250 hours to
complete
another half-time twist that spinning
selfie camera
inside the tunnel was he controlling the
camera was he
physically cracked yeah he grabbed the
camera
and that just made it feel different
let's
you know put a special lens on it give
it that fish-eye feel
j-lo who rocked halftime with shakira
last year was cheering in the stadium
with a-rod
the lv on her louis vuitton outfit
matching the roman numerals of this
year's super bowl
the performance sparked a flood of memes
including comparisons to
horror movie us and these in the gold
maze
me taking selfies after a night of
drinking and me trying to find my car in
the parking lot
five hours before the weekend hit the
stage miley cyrus got the crowd all
fired up
[Music]
a lot of us have been feeling broken
this year the 28 year old whose divorce
from liam hemsworth was finalized last
year
became emotional during her performance
at tick tock's tailgate party
i also wear my heart on my sleeve and so
with that
it gets broken a lot miley also gave a
sweet shout out to brittany
we love britney we are sorry britney
became a trending phrase on twitter
after the release of the new york times
documentary about her life
a source tells e.t brittany is aware of
the doc but hasn't seen it
fans are also slamming justin timberlake
for his part in their failed
relationship
but we're told britt wouldn't want her
fans to speak
negatively about him because she has the
utmost respect
for both justin and his wife back at the
game
a touching moment for singer jasmine
sullivan
jasmine honored whitney houston who sang
the national anthem 30 years ago
during her rehearsal with eric church
jasmine wore a tracksuit like the one
whitney wore during her performance
and people were quick to point out her
dazzling game day headpiece
was similar to whitney's in the
bodyguard there's a lot of pressure i
hear that this is
the anniversary of whitney houston's
version
and obviously nobody can do another
version of better version than whitney
but i'm just here to represent for my
people
and go up there and sing and bring some
soul to it
and e.t today with another super bowl
standout warren wawa snipe
who is deaf performed with jasmine eric
and her
in american sign language he won the
crowd over with his bright smile
and spoke to us through an interpreter i
really
felt a sense of pride and
being an american i wanted that emotion
to come through